hey bro listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b-25
mitchell Panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and I went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell like how do they know who you
are yeah okay um there are these things
called cookies where like if you go to a
site buy something it'll remember you
and then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to Google Earth and type
in your address
what is this tape recorder for what for
recording Michael is on vacation and
he's asked me to record all meetings and
to type up the transcripts okay uh Karen
any news from that law firm yeah the
deal closed yesterday it's a six month
commitment oh my god Dwight what are you
doing what you're not allowed to take
off your pants in the middle of the
office
I'm not y-you know what just back off
okay that's making me uncomfortable this
is sexual harassment by the way oh my
god he's got a knife I do not have a
knife no let the record show that Dwight
K Schrute is now completely nude and is
holding a plastic knife to Stanley's
neck let the record show that Jim
Halpert is a liar Dwight Roos not
wearing a baby's bonnet I am NOT here I
just walked in to I'd get his autograph
from I don't care do not just walk in
okay wait what is that on your stomach
is that a muppet babies - oh my god
Carrie is right that is animal from the
Muppets you can't see my Stu I am now
chopping off Phyllis's head with a
chainsaw ringing so we've been called
out to this hiking trail because there's
some reports that some teenagers are
digging bags of dog poop out of the
trash and having dog food fights I don't
believe it
oh my god it's real yeah I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna go do this I'm leaving hey
hey hello boys I am Leslie Knope I work
for the Department of Parks this is a
little fun this is fun
at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's famous chili the
trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot I'm serious about this
stuff I'm up the night before pressing
garlic and dicing whole Tomatoes i toast
my own ancho chiles it's a recipe passed
down from Malone's
for generations it's probably the thing
I do best
alright moving on to recycling you okay
run just a little tooth pain I'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins do you need to go to
the dentist Ron I don't like dentists
just a second
[Applause]
oh I'm sorry everybody what were we
talking about recycling dentist pulled
the tooth out yesterday but it's always
a good idea to demonstrate to your
co-workers that you are capable of
withstanding a tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
this is going to be a very good year
very good Jan is at home Jim is back my
protege Ryan is a corporate good stuff
Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team okay here's the situation your
parents went away on a week's vacation
they left the keys to the brand-new
Porsche okay mine well of course not
I'll just take it for a little spin and
maybe show it off to couple of friends
I'll just cruise around the neighborhood
I shouldn't yeah of course I should pay
attention here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walk and I picked up my car
phone a perpetrate like I was talking
sunroof was open the music was high in
that girl's hand was steadily moving up
my thought she had opened up three
buttons on a shirt so far I guess that's
why I didn't notice that police car I
can't believe it I made a mistake
my parents are the same no matter time
nor place so to all you kids all across
the land no need to argue parents just
don't understand
just a little something I know so what's
up someone is on fire in Rams at park
they need you to get down there right
away oh my god
it's a beautiful morning at
dunder-mifflin as I like to call it
great Bratton keep it running do I love
being manager I love my kids I love real
estate
I love ceramics I love my job I love
wrestling find out what language this is
my family care
Fafnir lost our femur jeez door box okay
team building on this side of the room
Stanley Phyllis Jim Ted
Elroy and this side of the room Pam
Meredith Phyllis Creed you never called
a meeting
welcome to manual control let me show
you around those are some chairs that's
a cat or possum oh this is a napkin
where I wrote down a cool name for a dog
bark Obama is that what's happening here
oh yeah yeah we found this bird outside
we tried to turn it into a work whistle
like in the beginning of the Flintstones
tougher than a look though we have a
massive pest problem in this town and
it's because the Animal Control
Department has been a disaster at
catching animals they're great at
ingesting and selling marijuana
this place has a miserable sack hole run
by two pothead losers it's completely
and utterly mismanaged thanks it doesn't
seem to be very poorly run but we've
only been here for two minutes there may
be a method to their madness there's
more than one way to skin a cat
four there's four ways to skin a cat
yeah we got like a huge vermin problem I
mean wouldn't have meaning to call
somebody about a bug you know nobody get
on the phone you're the people you would
be calling trippy oh you're fired you're
fired the whole department is fired how
this hurts this was one of my running
feet yo let's go to Jamaica no we should
go to Jamaica oh so what'd you say
it's kind of blurry it's better question
what kind of bear is best it's a
ridiculous question false like bear well
that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon dollar you
know what imitation is the most sincere
form of flattery so I thank you any
theft is not a joke Jim millions of
families suffer every year Michael oh
that's funny Michael
you